[Music]
so today we cancel the republican party
once again it's canceled for this news
as reported by the uh by cns news it
says the republican national committee
announced its partnership with the log
cabin republicans at donald trump's
mar-a-lago resort this weekend creating
its first pride coalition which will
invest in mobilize lgbtq plus
communities ahead of the 2022 midterm
elections according to fox news the
spirit of lincoln gala held at the
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida was
hosted by the log cabin republicans an
organization representing lgbtq
conservatives and their allies on
saturday night
as president trump referred to
mar-a-lago as his winter white house he
and his wife melania trump were the
guests of honor at saturday's event
now i criticized the rnc pride coalition
on twitter and it upset a number of
people uh many of them republicans
including richard grinnell who's the um
the acting or was the the acting
director of national intelligence under
trump and the first openly gay person to
serve at a cabinet level position
he was at the event at mar-a-lago as
well and he received an award as well i
think he took issue with my criticism
along with a number of other prominent
republicans both gay and straight
grinnell accused me of among other
things being uh he said i was from the
stone age for having a problem with the
rnc pride coalition
i take great exception to that
i am not from the stone age it would be
more accurate to say that i'm from the
middle ages
though frankly i would prefer the stone
age over the current age i would take
that in a heartbeat
now i have been repeatedly accused not
just because of this issue but in
general of trying to exclude gay people
from the conservative movement
that's not the case
what i want to exclude
what i say we must exclude if we want
conservatism to mean anything at all
is gay pride
i do not think that there should be an
lgbt pride coalition in the republican
party and i'll explain why and let me
know at the beginning that if we were
back in the ancient times of not the
stone ages or even the middle ages but
say five years ago it would have been
totally uncontroversial for me to
suggest that gay pride doesn't belong in
the conservative movement
but as we know the republican party is
on the same train as the democrat party
just a few cars behind and as the whole
the whole locomotive
speeds inexorably to the left the
republican party is never far behind
that's how a statement that would have
been so self-evident as to be boring
five years ago can suddenly be not only
provocative
but downright offensive today
so here's the problem with gay pride and
why it doesn't belong in the
conservative movement
it's hard to know even where to begin i
mean you often have that problem when
trying to explain things that should be
obvious
so i'll stick with two points here
starting with the most fundamental
gay pride is an ideology it's a
philosophy
and as such like any ideology or
philosophy it has a history
and we can trace that history
and when you trace the history of gay
pride which isn't hard to do because it
history goes back only a few decades
you find that it was from the beginning
has always been and is now an
anti-family anti-virtue
anti-christian left-wing phenomenon
there's a reason why harvey milk the
child raping peters is a gay pride hero
he may not be a hero of all gay people
individually but gay pride again is an
ideology
and within that ideology men like harvey
milk are honored and celebrated gay
pride parades are fully in accordance
with the gay pride philosophy
and that is why they are hedonistic
self-indulgent self-worshiping
hyper-sexualized spectacles of decadence
and debauchery it's not a coincidence or
a matter of happenstance that gay pride
parades and festivals take on this
character that's what gay pride the
ideology is all about and has always
been about
why is that well because gay pride
revolves around really it invented we
should say
sexual identity politics
according to gay pride ideology
according to sexual identity politics
the most important thing about a person
the number one defining trait is their
sexual proclivity
a person is encouraged to find their
identity to locate themselves within
this proclivity
that is not conservative
if that is conservative then
conservatism is totally
indistinguishable from leftism
at best it becomes a different side of
the same coin though i think it really
would be the same side of the same coin
or a coin where the two sides are so
similar that it would be really hard to
try and play heads or tails with them
again i emphasize
everything i've said here
would have been considered insane up
until about five years ago insane only
because it's so obvious that it
shouldn't need to be said
a segment on a conservative talk show
explaining why gay pride isn't
conservative would have been like a
segment on the weather channel
explaining why
the rain makes you wet
this just shows you how thoroughly how
cataclysmically the the ground has
shifted beneath our feet
and many people on the right have been
moved all the way to the left without
even noticing that they moved at all
this is what happens when you allow
yourself to passively float on the tide
of culture you look up one day and you
notice that you've drifted far from
where you started though you weren't
trying to go anywhere at all
right wing gay pride is as a concept
very similar to right-wing feminism
and there are indeed conservatives who
for years have been trying to develop a
conservative feminism
oftentimes they say that they want to
reclaim the spirit of feminism in its
original form
and its pure and edenic state
back in the mythic first wave period
when feminist pioneers were fighting for
the good you know fighting the good
fight and saying a lot of really
conservative things like uh quote the
bible and the church have been the
greatest stumbling blocks in the way of
women's emancipation
that was a elizabeth stanton godmother
of feminism
said that over 100 years ago
in the first wave
identifying the bible and church as the
enemies
in the first wave of feminism
in fact all of feminism's godmothers
said stuff like that about religion the
family men marriage
feminism as it turns out
was
at the time
still is
anti-family anti-christian anti-virtue
anti-man from its very inception
there is no pure form of it to return to
it is rotten to its core
like gay pride
feminism is one of the worst things to
ever happen to the human race it is one
of the greatest evils in history
it's killed 60 million babies and that's
just the start
and yet some conservatives still think
it's possible to be a conservative
feminist
not realizing
that it's it's it's you know it's not a
it's not a corruption of feminism in its
original form it is its culmination
today's feminism
is the culmination
of
the original feminism
a culmination not a corruption
the same can be said when you see drag
queen story hours or men in bondage gear
marching down the street in front of
children
that's not a corruption of gay pride it
is gay pride that's what the ideology of
lgbt pride stands for
and speaking of lgbt what about what
about the t in that um
in that initialism
i asked grinnell this and he didn't
answer but it's a good question
are we including the t in this
conservative pride
are we proud of transgenderism now too
are we embracing gender theory
perhaps looking for a pure conservative
form of gender theory
what's next conservative critical race
theory
conservative marxism
conservative communism where does it end
maybe we can come up with our own
conservative satanism
dems are the real satan phobes
that's where it ends really it ends in
confusion impotence the death of
anything resembling conservatism
unless we come to our senses and start
drawing clear lines
and until we do that i must say
the republican party is cancer and so is
gay pride gay pride is cancelled too of
course
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated